hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and I'm gonna start with an
apology if my voice sounds a little more
rumbly than usual today
apparently the punishing schedule of
podcasting and recording does not allow
you to take a day off just because you
have a cold and your voice is not
completely in good form but the audience
needs its content and I'm gonna provide
it no matter what shape my pipes are in
that particular day and the content
today is good we're gonna be talking
about the news we all know that we live
in a world now where there's all sorts
of information coming at us from all
sorts of places but much of the stuff
that we get Twitter social media
podcasts blogs its commentary on the
primary stuff the news reporting that is
telling us what is actually happening
out there in the world and I remember I
think that in my very first podcast
teaser trailer for mindscape I talked
about this issue of what we pay
attention to you know there are an
infinite number of facts there in the
world which ones do you notice which
ones do you communicate to other people
you and I do that every day but if
you're a news organization your choices
in this matter are incredibly important
and as it turns out as we will hear in
today's interview the news organizations
that make these choices don't always do
so for you know scientific data-driven
reasons there are some executives at a
news organization and they have
preferences and those preferences decide
what we hear so today's guest is Jessica
Yellin who has been a very well-known
reporter in various formats perhaps most
notably as the chief White House
correspondent at CNN for quite a while
but now jessica has left that all behind
she thinks that we need a new way of
delivering the news and she's trying to
pioneer different efforts herself
including an Instagram news feed that
you can all subscribe to
she's also written a book called savage
news which is a novel a thinly disguised
thinly fictionalized account of various
scandalous things going on in the news
world and this is a very important
conversation because we have to
understand what we're learning about the
world how we should interpret it and so
forth especially when there's so much
information coming in so let's go
[Music]
Jessica Yellin welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me this is
exciting yeah it kind of is exciting
it's definitely exciting for me because
we haven't had someone like you on the
podcast before but you know I know you
personally a little bit and I'm
interested both in kind of what the job
is that you do telling the news but then
also given how the podcast works the
theory behind how the news works and how
you think about it so you were you did
various jobs for ABC MSNBC CNN political
correspondent chief White House
correspondent let's help the audience
out a little bit by just saying like
what is it the day in the life like when
you're an on-air correspondent for a big
news organization how much time do you
spend writing reporting being on air and
stuff like that so it's very different
when you're at the White House versus
being in any other role when I was
paying my dues working the way my way up
I was in local news in Orlando covering
fires and murders and that kind of thing
and then I got to Good Morning America
where I covered even more gruesome
murders lots of tabloid celebrity
scandals and that life is just non-stop
go it's your phone beeps and you're at
dinner or you're on a date you know I
was young and you just have to stand up
and say they booked me on a flight to
Kentucky in two hours I got to go sorry
yes we have had a I did interview for
the podcast a chemist who works on
forensic chemistry yep murder so she
uses chemistry to help find murder
victims so there's the murder theme this
this quarter on my ins case sorry if
that's Grayson but it was it was a you
know excruciating ly difficult life in
terms of travel and that kind of thing
when you get to the White House it's
different right and you have a hard pass
which is what everybody who works in the
White House has and every there's this
class system about what color is your
hard pass we had the blue hard pass are
there soft passes I don't know what a
hard it's so interesting know that it's
just it is a it is hard so it's like a
click you can click it with your
fingernails you wear it around your neck
at all times and and so you get your
hard pass and you swipe in every day and
you walk through the Secret Service
security Shack just like every other
person who's
working in the White House and you go
into what's called the Brady press
briefing room you know it as you see it
on TV only the part you don't see behind
the scenes is where we physically work
it's a warren of cubicles in a
windowless space with a basement where
you have almost no room right and it's a
box you work in basically a closet with
four other people for other reporters
and producers in a box taking calls and
manically juggling everything that's
going on I presume that what I've seen
on the West Wing is more or less
completely accurate right it's not far
from reality except now with social
media
everything is at SuperSpeed so you have
twitter up you have interview everything
up all the time monitoring it and
especially when you're at a 24-hour
channel when I was at CNN
you're constantly racing to the camera
to get something on fast right and so
it's just fight or flight all the time
as your news when you're the White House
correspondent is your news basically
what comes to you in that briefing room
it's I'd separate that it's what comes
to you it's very hard to enterprise a
story which is what when you generate a
story that you find on your own because
the flood of incoming is so intense
however what happens in the briefing
room is usually the least relevant thing
it's Kabuki theater that's I would have
thought yeah it is so much about let me
ask the best question that I can use on
camera at far more than how do i frame
this to get the best answer I see so I
would have thought that the Kabuki
theater is coming from the press
officers giving you the briefing but
you're saying the reporters are just as
much part everybody's in the game
because there's cameras everywhere and
you want to be on camera what is your
goal like if you were playing this game
let's say let's say you were
enthusiastic who's playing along you
wanted to become the highest-paid
reporter on CNN what kinds of questions
would you be asking well you ask the
three parter that's why haven't you X is
that you know but so-and-so said this is
that really your answer so that you keep
cutting them off so that there's a two
way right because the waste TV news is
structured now it's all about conflict
and they've the powers-that-be have
decided viewers want conflict so you
don't ask this long question or the even
short question that elicits a subs
of answer you find the debate where's
the friction right and so the goal is in
that scenario how do I get that me
acting tough on camera and then but you
do a lot of reporting other than in that
briefing room so yeah that's just the
show part and then you have to go back
to your booth and your little cubicle
and just dial you call people you're
texting your emailing all day and it's
not you know the White House each
administration I've been dealt with has
become increasingly more difficult to
cover because they're more tightly held
until this one which is everything's
publicist but anyways as long as it
doesn't have to do with Putin but
everything's public you'd purport you
know you're calling Congress you need to
triangulate right you find sources
outside the White House you tell you
what they know is going on inside then
you call inside to say I know this you
want to correct me or you walk sometimes
you can you have access to part of the
White House okay so you can walk into
part of it where the communications team
is and linger and try to get information
and then there's the whole scene that
happens on the driveway where everything
comes out and asks you know you do
questions but the real reporting is
stuff you don't see on camera and you're
in a room with four other people or at
least are you listening to their course
always I mean it's it's the craziest
thing because you want to hold your
information but you're in a space where
you cannot so one of the things that
happens is you'll see a lot of White
House reporters pacing on the driveway
and that's when they're talking to
someone they're talking to someone and
it's like sleeting and snowing but it's
your only privacy yeah okay very good
and but is there a lot of time outside
the White House also well when the
president travels you travel or somebody
in your team travels so sometimes it's
on Air Force One you fly your first one
sometimes it's on the support plane the
Charter and then yeah you're out about
around town you're back at the bureau
sometimes you do go into the country to
do a story and then the White House
correspondent becomes the political
reporter on the campaign right sometimes
the campaign or the conventions these
are special events where you're your
mode is a little bit different well once
the campaign starts by White House when
when I went on the 2008 campaign I
covered Obama I left for that at the end
of No
2007 with a suitcase and the first time
I came home to repack my suitcase was in
March and sometimes you're flying to a
different city or state every day and
this is everyone does just what you sign
up for your and do people do this for
years and years and years it gets it
gets really exhausting yeah and so
either you at some point you'll say this
is my life I'm doing this I'm gonna do
this right for me I said okay I've had
that experience I can't keep doing this
and how much is the who's deciding what
counts as a story is this the initiative
of the individual reporters well this is
the question isn't it to me that's the
most important question what are the
most important questions who decides
what counts as news my frustration in
the news business in my experience was
that the reporter who's on the ground
witnessing the events has too little
influence in deciding the story has too
little say in whether it should be
covered and how it should be covered and
that's a function of how our
organizations have changed news
organizations have changed as profit
became you know accessible like as they
became extremely profitable and as that
became the priority I mean I imagine the
profit was always the priority was is it
Morde I always worry about doing
comparisons between things today and
things back in the past because you know
we see things through rose-colored
glasses so here's how I see it and you
know people will disagree when news
first came along you know in at the
network level it was a loss leader right
it it was part of the agreement to be
able to use the airwaves and so there
was not pressure for them to monetize
and then the way I understand it when 60
minutes came along and actually made
money it was the first time network
executives realize we can make a profit
off of this and so then you got the
morning shows which are more
entertainment they started making a lot
of money but the news was still
sacrosanct evening news cable changed
things right because they are regulated
by the same that same FCC equal time
rules don't apply and and then for me
it's partly about the fact that all of
these companies were bought by publicly
traded
raishin where it was important to show
profit growth over last year to the
shareholders all the time and it really
became a short-term it that short-term
thinking impacted the newsroom to the
point that I was told it is your guys's
job to increase our profit ten percent
over last year and giving guidance as to
what that meant or just you know do
something that will get more I bow my
the way I took it was comply yeah okay
comply with explicit directions well
what happens is I mean I think when
you're a reporter
you're a natural skeptic you question
Authority and you're a little rebellious
right to work in a news organization you
can't be very rebellious because it's a
very it's a bureaucratic system you have
to be obedient but you have that streak
in you and what would what happened
increasingly is that management would
tell us what the story is and you'd say
back actually it's this and they would
say did you not hear me I'm telling you
this is the story now it's not they're
making up facts it's not a fake news
thing and pointed you it say this is how
we've decided is best to frame it for
our programming needs aka eyeballs aka
ratings and that's the story you need to
tell and so let's sort of flesh this out
maybe with I don't know if you have
examples or how when did you start
noticing this feeling this way when did
you start being a national reporter well
so okay so I got to the White House
under bush and I can take it back
further than that when I was covering um
when I first got to the national level
it was the Iraq war okay and you
remember with the second Iraq war yes
sorry the second Iraq war 2003 and you
remember the way I got in trouble
eventually because I later said on
television that we were under pressure
to cover it in a way that was consistent
with the patriotic fever in the nation
yeah it was a different time like every
every time is different but we I think
they forget giving the highly inflamed
political feelings everyone has right
now
they were pretty darn inflamed back in
the early 2000 well it was it was right
after 9/11 everybody felt so you know
the sense of connected connectedness and
nationalism really and patriotism and
then we went to war and it was sort
look at we're gonna stand up for
ourselves right and so everything was
channeled into this sort of intense
rah-rah sporting event show of force
remember this it was called the shock
and awe campaign right and what we did
was consistent with that and so my
experience a couple even from a remove I
was not at war I was a junior baby
reporter then but I just watched what
happened and there was a decision like
the narrative here is were there were
here were kickin ass were the USA and
things that weren't in that vein really
weren't prioritized well I remember
there was controversy at the time about
how reporters were embedded with
military units well that's the way we do
things now I mean yeah and that but it
was very much like a TV show there were
like vans with reporters on them and
cameras as they marched into that like
they're driving to Baghdad with the
troops yeah it was a show and you know
so that kind of opened my eyes - oh
we're producing the war right like this
is not just Wars happening we'll airdrop
in and cover what's happening it was
let's march in together with the cameras
rolling and we're gonna kick some ass
and then it just ice and then I got to
the White House after that under bush
and saw that as the war was popular with
the American people we covered it in a
way that was Rawat as the poll numbers
started to fall we became increasingly
critical did you personally go to
journalism school or anything like I did
not I mean I presume that in journalism
school but maybe even you know in your
tenure as a cup reporter the the the
myth the the self conception is that
there is an adversarial relationship
between reporters and people they cover
even if it's a friendly adverse ation
adversarial relationship you're not
there to give them publicity you're
there to dig out the truth that they
might be trying to hide from you so you
you think that at least at this time in
the cable news world this was not being
respected well it is hard when you're in
a war zone because you're dependent on
the military to imagine for your own
security so that's a tricky relationship
it's much easier when you're back at the
White House to be adverse there
real did you spend time in Arakan I tell
her I didn't cover the worse but they
are you know like you said it was a
there was definitely pretty explicitly
an attempt to stage manage what was seen
and so I guess what are you saying which
was not clear to me at the time was that
the that was a profit-making thing from
the point of view of the networks they
went along with that just for those
reasons well they crafted it in a way
that would be popular with viewers yeah
so that they get more eyeballs is the
way I see it it was well it they talk
about news as programming which if you
live in LA you know that's how TV
executives talk about their TV slate
it's making a program people want to
watch as opposed to we are journalists
covering events as they happen and we
cover what matters most and that you
make a judgement about this is what
matters most and it might be less sexy
than the thing we were planning but
we're gonna cover it anyway because it's
important and it's our job and it's not
necessarily a political slant easy
because you're saying that this was you
know Pro administration the thing was
popular and then it changed
it's like Syria's more boring than
Trump's tweets so Syria gets less
coverage yeah even though potentially on
certain days it might be more
significant so one of my questions is is
it is the opinion of the corporate
executives that a certain thing is going
to be popular and make us money are they
correct or that's their gut feeling or
do they have data saying no certain
kinds of coverage gets us the profits we
want so they do have analytics within so
they have a framework and within their
framework of what works with viewers
they have all these analytics and you
know measurement metrics to decide
what's gonna be popular too so there's
boards in the newsroom showing what's
on.com that's doing well and you'll see
one story start to rise and clicks right
and so that becomes the top story and so
more people are then assigned to cover
that top story because it's getting more
clicks okay um there's also eyeball
meters so that people can now tell
executives can now tell as viewers are
turning the channel so oh they were
watching for that topic but they're
turning for this topic let's go back to
that topic that kind of thing
now the flaw in this from my point of
view is that this is all based on their
framework which is news needs to be told
like sports viewers want news that feels
like ESPN so it has to be all that
conflict jargon competition and outrage
and they program everything through that
filter I can get into why how it got to
be that way but the bottom line is I
know for a fact because I've done
research it leaves that leaves a huge
audience unaddressed because so many
people feel alienated by that sports
like coverage they just turn it off and
so they've already limited their
audience to the people who want news
that feels like sports and yes within
them their metrics and their analytics
can measure how many they're getting but
I believe that there's a massive
unaddressed audience out there and
they're just missing the opportunity I
even are a million aided by that in the
context of sports like these show on
ESPN was just two people shouting at
each other and like that this tells me
nothing about anything bingo so how did
it get that way you said you have your
own theory so late on it so here's my
theory when all these news executives
who were running the network's now came
up everything was about the ad dollar
right it wasn't really subscriptions and
the people who paid the most for an
eyeball or were the car dealers and car
dealers wanted a young man what I'm
sorry when do you think we're talking
now late 90s early 2000s and car dealers
wanted the young man right and because
he's gonna but they thought he makes the
car purchase decision and he owns the
car your brand for life
PS we've now found that's untrue women
make the car purchase decision and this
generation isn't buying cars you know
the futures car lists or uber anyway so
flawed assumption now but the idea is
that 18 year-old man isn't that
interested in news but he likes if you
wants conflict if you tell it like
conflict it'll feel more engaging and so
everything you do when you're in the
news business I would always constantly
hear how do we do with the demo and
that's the demo it's eight men ages 18
to 35 demographic yeah the demographic
so the demographic
refers to people ages 18 to 35 but the
most desirable eyeball is the guy
because he's the hardest to get I joke
it's it's news is run by the rules of
dysfunctional dating you have to chase
the guy who doesn't want you right right
but I mean I would like to think that in
this so let me be idealistic we have a
big elaborate ecosystem of news right
there's many different ways people can
get the news now it has any one of the
major cable networks said well everyone
else is doing that let's try something
slightly different I would disagree that
within the traditional news field we
don't have that many choices it's much
more like the old studio system you have
three networks and you have three cable
channels you have six outlets for TV
news right so not that many not that
many and they all compete with each
other and they play by the same rules
the exception is CBS which has tried to
differentiate itself by being calmer
more substantive less fast-twitch and
they've been rewarded for it but I do
think I think the other piece of this
which is worth noting in our moment is
the background of everybody who's a news
president until recently has been the
same they're all mostly all white guys
in their 50s who grew up and Upper West
Side of New York and they have the same
values in the same backgrounds they all
went to the same school that's right and
this is what they think works right and
and they can convince themselves that
it's perfectly objective and scientific
right well it's making money for their
companies so right right so we mentioned
I mean we painted this in the context of
the second Iraq war is the same story
told in different ways you know just a
more conventional political coverage you
know conventions and racism yeah I mean
so my might take them with the way this
is expressed is first of all yes
political coverage the problem with it
is it's all horse race it's literally
this one's up this one's down what are
the poll numbers and I think this is a
roading our democracy nothing short of
that because it is the News's job to
inform the public and we are failing to
do that by constantly covering this game
without telling people how does this hit
you at home and I'll be more specific
constantly you know if you watch the
news you know that at the end of the
election it's all about the undecided
voter we spend four months chasing these
people and when you get into the
granular stuff you find a lot of these
undecided voters or women and the
conventional wisdom is they're not
paying attention so they decide late and
they often do with their husbands say
they're doing but if you probe that more
closely what they say is no no I'm
reading things I'm watching the news it
doesn't speak to me and when I looked
more closely at that because I did
research what they're literally saying
is if this candidate wins how will it
change my life if that candidate wins
how will that change my life we're not
breaking it down in a way that connects
on a level that's personal and part of
that is we're also not explaining what
the thing is so we'll talk about tax
reform without saying it specifically
means this or we talk about terror trade
wars without ever saying what a tariff
is not everybody knows just take the
minute to explain and is that because
why is that why do we not take the
minute to explain well I always tried to
and people were like Jessica no one
wants to hear that because it's
considered boring and it's not a game if
you're there explaining what a tariff is
you're not in a fight yeah that's not
conflict you could lose one of those
demo eyeballs I still I have this
feeling and maybe it's because I'm just
completely biased but if there were a
concerted effort even on one of these
six news outlets on TV to give people
good explanations of what was going on
to explicitly pander to people who
wanted to understand rather than just
follow the horse race that would be a
big hit maybe I'm crazy well I love you
for saying that because that's the
business I'm launching which is news
that's focused on the viewers
understanding and we can talk about that
a bit but I just it's not it's not what
they're in the business of doing I part
of the other piece of this is the when
you're in political journalists in
Washington you get consumed with
breaking the thing first there's a lot
of reporting for each other right so
you're in the bubble and you're really
talking to your sources on Capitol Hill
while you're on TV or talking to your
sources in the White House and showing
off your colleagues how you you know who
you got to give you a scoop yeah and so
it's so in circle
it leaves the viewer out and part of the
reach so part of the reason we're not
explaining is because we're moving too
fast to impress each other so let's take
it from the angles of different people
who are in the game right now so if you
were giving advice to a young person who
had just been appointed senior White
House correspondent like how would you
want them to behave to try to make
things better
well I mean in the idea low vision and
that's what we are we're an idea yeah
we're the happiest time you know you
have a vibrant editorial debate in the
morning with the smart people you work
with because these networks are filled
with unbelievably talented journalists
decide what you think the three most
important stories are and start asking
questions about those and and ignore
what's on what's trending on.com right
at this minute because you're the chief
White House correspondent and if you
decide this is a big story you can make
that story trend right we followed too
much we forget the power we have you are
the media you say what matters there's
too much of this well we got to go along
with what the conversation is and not
enough we define the conversation and
then when you approach the thing I try
to do when I approach each story is
think about what assumptions I'm making
here what assumptions and I'm making
about what the audience understands and
even to the lingo I'm using so you know
we talk about Michael Collins going to
testify but when he goes before Congress
everything he says related to Russia
will be in closed session so we'll still
get the transcripts and we'll see know
eventually blah blah but we most people
don't know what closed session is so you
lost them yeah take a minute and I know
that doesn't seem revolutionary but it
is because when you start to do that you
pick up people who feel left out by the
news and they start to engage and care
and literally that's how you inform the
electorate in a democracy and you know
it's everything you're saying is very
much like science communication right
where you have so much jargon so many
the people who are experts are very
often used to talking in a certain way
taking certain things for granted and
then they are baffled as to why people
are not more excited by what they're
saying and how do you unpack that how do
you reverse that I think that you know
yeah we do it a lot of different ways
different people have different
strategies very often it's simply a
matter of talking to people to figure
out what it is they don't understand
right like no one is born understanding
physics you you learn it but then once
you learn it it's very easy to forget
what you knew or what you didn't know
back in the day right so talking to
people and you know just seeing oh
that's what you don't understand okay
I'll try to explain that using analogies
with things trying to relate to things
that they're familiar with in their
everyday lives right but I imagine this
is similar in science there must be a
group of scientists who don't care
they're like if you're not in if you
don't know what we're talking about
you're not in the circle we're not
speaking to you yeah that's called
almost all scientists yes that's right
and that's how I think political
coverage is now it's like you're either
in the game like you're a sports fan
meaning a politics fan or you're not and
if you're not we're not you know we're
not gonna get you we know that my belief
is that's not true
right and so if you were then rather
than giving advice to the cup reporter
if you were giving advice or even were
granted the position of boss of a
network well that how would you change
things I mean it's it's it's about
thinking all the time about how does
this impact the sewer at home how do I
make this relevant to their life what is
the piece of this that matters to their
life and how do I get outside of the
studio and outside of Washington one of
the worst things that's happened in
coverage lately is they're always in the
studio the job is to leave the studio
the news is out there is it a money
thing is it just like cost-cutting it's
easier to sit in Washington DC than to
go into the world
I think reasons one through three are
yes it's way cheaper to have people on
set than to send a satellite truck you
know a producer a cameraman a sound
person and a reporter five people who
your overnighting and paying their per
diems and etc so that's one piece the
other is news executives increasingly
like to produce the news I'm saying
right and if you've just deployed me to
the border but now some big Russia thing
breaks you're stuck paying for me at the
border but you need you want to change
topics
and so when everyone's in studio they
can rapidly decide what this they can
control the story much more effectively
and they can also get in the report
person's ear and tell them no no stay on
Russia stay on Russia yes what is your
take on the whole I want to say the Fox
News phenomenon but very broadly
construed the idea of media outlets that
are more or less explicitly partisan one
way or the other so I'm gonna probably
piss off a lot of your listeners by
saying this but I kind of think that's
our future we're dividing into red and
blue as consumers it's not just a news
when you look at how people spend and
shop and live we're clustering into
communities of like-minded people we are
shopping in the same ways based on your
politics I'm not surprised that this is
happening and it's a little bit like
Napster like you can't put it back in
the box it's there what's important is
to now be transparent I would like these
networks to be a little more transparent
this is where we're coming photos at me
oh ok in terms of their political slant
so rather than just we're fair and
balanced right while obviously having a
point of view yeah you know be a little
more clear and facts aren't negotiable
like whatever your point of view I think
it's effective to say here are the facts
of the shutdown if you're a Democrat
you'll make the case that the shutdown
is at stalemate for this reason if
you're a Republican you'll make the case
that it's a stalemate for this reason so
you're showing the difference but the
facts of the shutdown remain the same
but the number of facts that one could
in principle talk about is infinitely
large
I mean a big part of the filter of the
bias if you want to call it that whether
it's a not necessarily pejorative term
but we choose what to talk about right
and that's one thing that a network can
control a little bit absolutely and I
also think there's nothing wrong with
that you become a journalist because
we're saying you're the one we trust to
help decide what we're talking about and
what bothers me is when journalists say
well we have to cover this we don't have
a choice or you know you got to give
both sides we don't have a choice of Pro
climate change and anti with equal
weight right and know you're there
because we asked you to do the research
and tell us what you think is true yeah
there was this video not video there was
this little picture going around the
internet recently CNN had a segment I
don't know the details whether it was a
new segment or an opinion
segment but they were saying stop giving
a voice to climate change deniers and
they had a picture of various people
denying climate change but two of the
four pictures were from CNN what is it
is definitely mixed messages there well
there's also this false balance you know
we have this point of view so we have to
have that point of view right and that
sometimes is what makes me nuts like on
climate change you can have climate
changes happening this is the aggressive
version of addressing it here's a
conservative aversion of addressing it
you know you can have a conversation
within the space of fact right and and
at some point yes Fox is going to
marshal different facts on a topic than
MSNBC it's also the job of the consumer
to be a little news savvy well that's a
very interesting point I mean I'm a big
believer again also with science that
you have to ask something of the
audience right like they have to be a
little bit aware of what's going on it
has to be a given date right absolutely
I mean it's just a critical thinking
skill and we it's our job to help train
people maybe like you know here's some
media literacy I mean now I'm getting
now I'm on Instagram and so I get a lot
of feedback from the audience and I do a
lot of that you know where they are you
know they don't know who to believe can
I believe this it's in the New York
Times they hate Trump you're like okay
yes the New York Times has a frame right
now yes they're very you could tell a
little shrill but when you have a
reported story with an investigative
reporter I know this guy yeah that's you
go with it you can believe it I mean but
do you foresee in the future as there
are more more ways for people to get
their news and more of them are just
getting it from Facebook and Twitter
that even that goes away there's no such
thing as reported news there's just
what's your friend shared with you on
Facebook I believe that the future is
incredible I think the news
organizations are like the old studio
system where you had actors married for
life to a studio and they had to do
their movie with that studio but if a
movie happens somewhere else they can't
be in it that's how it is now you got to
pitch your story to your network if they
don't want it you're done I think the
future is all of that is gonna be people
leave and you'll be seeing individual
reporters on Facebook and Instagram and
all these spaces and whatever emerges
and new media platforms and people will
start to follow the individuals they
trust interesting and I think it is a
mistake to assume that because you're
getting your news on social people don't
want credible journalism so I think
there's a place for credible journalists
reporting they're well sourced well
researched information on social media
in new channels outside the network
system in my more pessimistic moments I
see people on either political side
clearly believing something just because
they want to believe it right regardless
of the credibility of this well isn't
there neuroscience on this you could
probably tell me it's a tough one I mean
yet people have all sorts of cognitive
biases but one of the things that is you
know for better for worse about the
proliferation of places to get your news
is you can sort of give in to your worst
impulses there right you can just hear
from sources that are gonna tell you
what you want to believe you know yeah
we're sorting into our like-minded
communities yeah and I don't know though
the way out necessarily I think one way
out is to have trusted voices um that
you get a large following behind and you
know it's like the Walter Cronkite
effect he'll never exist again with that
size of a following but you'll have
individuals who are trusted voices in
different spaces well one of the things
we see on Fox News for example as well
as on the other cable networks is this
back and forth on the channel between
straight news and opinion or commentary
right and my feeling is that on Fox a
vast majority of the audience comes from
the opinion commentary shows so that
just gives them more and more incentive
to be more and more extreme in some
sense yeah well my perception was always
because a lot of the Fox report we all
work together at the White House they
were my friends they were my colleagues
the reporters were always kick-ass the
bias comes in the night time it was
especially the primetime shows but as
you get later in the afternoon and you
know it's hard for as a viewer to make
that distinction and you were very smart
to make it but it's the reporters are
reporting information sourced we
information they sometimes have to
report in to anchors who are untethered
from those things is there room for
something maybe CNN to have a balance of
that news plus opinion but keep the
opinion balanced right like does not try
to be the mouthpiece of one side or the
other I mean like the New York Times
tries to do with its op-ed pages
although of course there's still a slant
there I don't know I think the problem
the problem is on a CNN for example in
the effort to be balanced they often
book Trump you know supporters who had
no experience in politics before this
moment and say things that just aren't
productive like it's not part of the
conversation right so how do you get
around that how do you do that in an
intelligent way where you have a balance
that doesn't necessarily reflect the
politics of the administration right but
we can imagine you know we're in the
happiest time line you know our ideal
division here so like some day we won't
have Trump anymore maybe we'll have just
very respectable legitimate parties on
both sides my question is can will it be
such a splintering that every outlet
outs aside or do you think that you can
still see you know outlets trying to
stay above that footing oh I think
you'll have outlets that are trying to I
mean I call it reporting straight news
and not you know yes I think you'll
absolutely have that and I think you
know after this moment where everybody's
hysterical the corrective will be people
will be very sober very substantive
possibly wooded and who knows right but
we do it's a pendulum yeah and so yes I
can imagine that will go to a place
where we're on you know neutral
reporting will be what's valued but
there's but there will always be you
know there's this interest in having
opinionated voices I mean like my
question is can the new opinionative
voices stick together or can we imagine
that that like I remember in the early
days of Fox News
there was Hannity was on with Alan
Colmes right at least gave some nod to
oh yes we'll have one person from each
side that didn't work I just think
what's happened now is that the
opinionated voices have become
extreme there's no conversation anymore
it's just talking points being flung
back and forth and that's why you never
get learning so my my ideal is somebody
told me that in the Netherlands when you
testify before in court when two experts
come they do something called the hot
tub maybe when your can teach us a
little more I'm sure I'm gonna mangle it
but that the experts who are the
opposing sides begin by submitting a
document that shows their area of
consensus this is where we overlap these
are the topics on which we agree well
that's how we see similarly and then you
testify to the differences and I love
that idea right so that at some point
you establish common ground and then you
discuss around that I think that would
be a fascinating way to do these
conversations another option I like how
they do it in Britain where you don't
have to Talking Heads yell at each other
you bring one person on and go very deep
with them and then you can go on the
other side very deep but you actually
then get to as you're saying the theory
of the thing right and what's happening
now is you're just it's like shadow
vision well and also they intentionally
you know there are people who are the
ones who appear on TV who are just very
obviously their job is to present the
advocacy case for one side or the other
and they're their belief in sticking to
the truth might come or go but rather
than having an expert who might have an
opinion one side or the other but
nevertheless wants to get it right
they're just just fighting for their
team oh well but that's by design so
when I was on the inside I'd find this
new this expert I'd see a TED talk or
whatever I said this person so smart
they know their stuff and they speak
clearly let's get them on and the
response would be will they bring the
heat yeah and so we literally cast four
people who will yell at each other hold
their ground it's about that
that's not incidental that's what the
show is so this needs to change you're
gonna change it so you left your job I
guess as chief White House correspondent
intentionally and so you're trying to
launch a new project to bring people
news in a different way tell us about
that uh that the project is called I
called hashtag
news not noise we want to bring you news
and tell you what's the noise and it's
on Instagram so first of all you can
find it on Instagram under my name which
is Jessica Yellin and I am reporting the
news there and what happened it sort of
started to take off which is exciting
yeah but what happened is so I laughed I
wrote a novel about Mike's you know like
a what's it like to be a woman in the
news business that's the critique and
then I did research into what we're
talking about how was the news impacting
viewers and I looked at something
specifically called news avoidance
people who want information seek it out
and then turn it off or want information
and don't seek it out they're avoiding
the news for a reason
even though they want it and what I
found is that it is triggering so much
anxiety in a part of the population they
just can't engage it's heavily female
but it's but not exclusively and it's
not that they don't care about the news
and it's not that bad news is scary and
they must avoid it it's the tone and the
negativity and that yelling the show
thing yeah it's the shouting makes them
like I I have enough going on I've kids
and a boss and my car's broken like stop
yeah so how do you reach that audience
and I was told forever and so I did the
research and found out yeah there's this
audience and they want the news told
differently but all the conventional
wisdom is no one's gonna watch that
right now shouting why would I watch
that this is precisely why they do the
shouting to get ratings right so I went
on Instagram because I figured this is a
place I can test out another way
there's an interesting choice I mean I'm
not a I'm a little bit on Instagram but
I think of it as a place to share
pictures of my food I did it a couple of
reasons there one it doesn't have that
same patina of like is there fake news
here right right sudden sullied
- it's very female and I knew that this
was a lot like the first target for this
thing is female and it's a nice place
like people aren't nasty to each other
and Instagram as much as they are on the
other platforms right and I just thought
at least there will be gains me or maybe
to each other or maybe that was seeking
meanness yes exactly yeah and nobody's
really doing the news there I mean you
just don't have that yeah so I start
and I do a post that's like an explainer
where I break down a topic in the news
basically what is a tariff or people are
comparing Michael Collins testimony to
John Dean who's John Dean what did he do
like many people don't know or even
every person in the Russia investigation
like what are they what's their piece of
this and then there's a section that's
video and I do a video newscast in there
and what and I start I started it
because I wanted to see will people pay
attention if the news isn't hysterical
panicky screaming and then and then I
just wanted to I just want to see what
the reaction was anyway started doing it
when you say you you mean you personally
it's just you right I mean it is it was
so hard at the beginning because I was
the chief White House correspondent had
a cameraman I had like the you know and
then there I am sitting in my living
room with my iPhone alone thinking am I
really gonna do this yeah like what if
people laugh what if nobody cares what
if I'm awful what if a million things so
that was really hard are your video
segments short long okay so this is the
thing about Instagram every video has to
be 15 seconds so what I do is I break a
newscast down and I say every piece of
it in 15 seconds so um you know today
there is big news in the Russia
investigations and you're it's a
bombshell New York Times report you're
not gonna believe next 15 seconds is yes
and so people advanced through those
15-second things and that's in I mean
Instagram lets you have multiple things
on one post so that's all in one post
yes so it's cold there's this thing
called stories on one part of it up on
top and you can watch video and usually
that's used for you know I wonder why I
went to Hawaii look at my new bathing
suit my dog you know it's usually
shallow fluffy stuff but it this is me
talking to camera or I'll post an
article that I think is important and
I'll summarize it and give you a link so
you can swipe up and read it okay and
then sometimes I do interviews yeah
about a topic that's in the news and
people come up and we do the two way
so what is the archiving like is it easy
to find old things that you've done as
you're explaining all these wonderful
things like maybe I would still wanna
know what a tariff is next year so yeah
so the part that's like those explainers
I was saying they stay forever and
they're I don't even I don't even know
what you call they're in the thing in
the aids so Graham called the gallery or
the feed okay so if you go to my page
you'll see all these pictures and if you
tap look at each of those pictures
there's a caption with them that
explains the story so they stay forever
mmm
then there's the video piece and those
last 24 hours okay so they're like the
Buddhist ideal they're going to the wind
yes 24 hours later I try to remember to
save them to this one highlight section
so people can go back and watch but I
don't always remember anyway kind of
charming though you know like it's it's
the news it's its current right then and
yeah which is different than an
explainer which should hopefully be good
for a long time exactly and the most
satisfying thing is when you do an
explainer that you can keep reusing like
we're back to this story remember if you
missed it here it is like what is a
national emergency as everyone's talking
about the wall right right yeah no I
think that the whole idea of explaining
things is way undervalued in our news
media ecosystem entirely so more of that
would be great people want to know yeah
yeah so as it's working so yeah so what
the fun things been so I don't know how
celebrities happy everybody but Amy
Schumer the comedian became an early
follower okay and she decided to
announce her pregnancy on my Instagram
feed and she announced who she's like
she did this political thing around the
election and said in PS I'm pregnant
okay so when she did that all of a
sudden the world exploded because you
know when a celebrity announces her
pregnancy it's like the biggest news in
the world and it I'm not saying it
anyway so then all of a sudden everybody
noticed I was doing this and its really
become there there's a following for it
and the most interesting and satisfying
part to me is that the audience is
really engaged so I have people who ask
questions and then other people in the
community answer them and you can see
this dialogue going on and then I also
have a different kind of connection to
the audience so I'll do a story and
people will instantly
message me saying I don't know what that
meant hmm so then I know I have to break
that down that goes back to that my idea
you know how scientists can be better
communicators just asking people what it
is they don't understand exactly and you
don't have that feedback when you're on
television so that's really gratifying
and so this raises a question of you
know there's a very wise person once
said don't read the comments anything
about anything and you know largely it's
kind of a shame because sometimes
comments on the Internet are wonderful
and I've learned a lot from people but
many of them are pointless or toxic or
whatever so is it because of Instagram
or because of your feed or how engaged
are you in those comment section I'm
pretty engaged I mean sometimes it's too
much and I can't I'm busy but I do my
best so far knock on wood people have
been very nice I mean yes you get the
occasional whatever you know screed but
I'm surprised how completely open and
there's sort of like news sponges like
think so one of the things so I say it's
news not noise and the way I cover
things is I say this is news and then
I'll say here's another story that got a
ton of attention today in the news
business but it's noise okay I'm gonna
tell you what happened but you don't
have to pay attention to it if it
interests you follow it just like you'd
follow US magazine people but it doesn't
matter
right so that's noise so people are
constantly messaging back and forth like
I found noise I found news is this noise
or news yeah that's cool and that's the
kind of stuff you get in comments not
the mean stuff you get on Twitter it's a
much nicer experience it seems I mean
maybe this is a disadvantage so tell me
if I'm wrong but it seems that it's so
different from the other stuff on
Instagram that if I have an Instagram
feed yours will stand out for better for
worse I do I think that's part of it
nobody's really tried it this way before
and so it's distinctive for now I'm sure
that'll change because everything
changes
then your plan is to grow this and so my
my goal is to now that I've seen that
people really want it is find a way to
do more because it's very hard to do a
full newscast and really answer people's
questions and I on Instagram as it is
right now I also want to bring other
reporters in
mm-hmm and so the question is how do you
do that how do you grow it what you know
what's the next step but you're the goal
is to be a you know a substitute for the
your biggest news source whatever that
is the New York Times or CNN or whatever
like fill that niche someday that's
where I'd like to go I think of it as at
least at this stage like look in four
years could there be a day when we're
doing investigative reporting and
breaking the stories ourselves or soon
or yes that'd be amazing for right now
what I'm trying to do is let's say
you're a super busy person and you do
not have time to follow every twist and
turn of what's going on all day long and
those notifications on your phone are
making you crazy we gotcha
so come to us at the end of the day
we're gonna distill it all in a way that
doesn't make you feel stupid but really
explains it tells you what happened what
mattered what you can ignore and a
reason to still feel good about the
world and is there still a race to be
really quick when something breaks so no
and that's so hard for me that's such a
smart question shot oh my god youto get
it so one of the things are the ethos is
is it's more important to process and
distill the thing and then make it as
succinct as possible for the viewer and
that means letting the story unfold
letting it breathe let it happen in the
world a little bit before you do it but
my muscle memory is run to the camera
get it on now I gotta go so I have to
like everyone around me is like no
Jessica don't report don't build state
stop put your phone down that's I mean I
I kind of didn't know exactly what you
mean because for a long time my biggest
for a little while anyway my biggest
social media presence was on Twitter but
now I have a podcast and on Twitter you
say something in most of the responses
are within half an hour right later
respond now I have a podcast it takes an
hour and half just to listen to it I'm
like very disappointed when you know
half an hour after posting it I haven't
had any space yet we're so quickly
trained for that instant feedback it's
this part of our brain right you know I
don't know what it is but yeah instant
right away well there is this thing
evolving they're calling it the slow
news movement which is both what we're
talking about not reacting too rapidly
and also reporting stories over a longer
time so they're more in-depth and it's
good because it's a difference III never
really liked the phrase long reads I
don't know if you know this word because
you know gives the idea that okay we
should read things that are more than
500 words and really you'll go into them
and and and get it right but that's
great but we can also be correct in
short amounts of words right it's a
whole different angle different axes
that we're trying to focus on and that's
what I'm trying to do and PS it's very
hard to fully understand a complex
situation and then break it down in a
very short way that is accurate and
clear is a challenge I did this very
explicitly with my last book the big
picture so the big sprawling book where
I covered all sorts of things and some
of the topics were pretty heavy so every
chapter was like three or four pages
long right and there were fifty chapters
so you could you know you could just
focus on getting that one little bit
process it and then move on it's hard it
is very possibly yeah I'm not doing in
my current book your current but it's a
much shorter book but it's only ten
chapters rather than fifty chapters
right because it's like it's a different
all the different modes are okay right
you know the new book the mode is I'm
gonna dive in here I'm gonna wallow in
the details I'm going to accumulate this
knowledge and hopefully it will it will
help me come out the other end with
something really deep rather than here
is a survey many many things like the
new book about the new book about
quantum mechanics you know then
especially the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
you there's you just have to sort of
steal yourself and try to get into the
weeds a little bit whereas you know the
big picture there's a lot of deep stuff
in there but it was a lot more
signposting a lot more like trust me
there's more here but this is a glimpse
right so when you're you and you're the
expert in the field is it still hard to
write a book cuz when I wrote my first
book I was like halfway through I'm like
I'm out in the middle the ocean I don't
know what I'm gonna do I think it is
that's a great question it's different
for different people I know plenty of
professional journalists who hate
writing books you know they love writing
a few thousand word article or whatever
but with a book that they just get lost
I love it you do I'm never happier than
when I have a hundred thousand words in
front of me I get to do they
my way right I get to explain things and
they're the current books supposed to be
like 80 or 90 thousand words and I feel
very constrained admire that but so and
so it's going well so far is there going
to be at some point like a separate web
page yes so what I'm thinking about now
is how do you turn this into something
that's more yeah of a news brand and
what does that look like where does it
live how does that work and so I'm
having those conversations and it's you
know that's a whole new world and
learning curve for me and I have to ask
how do you make money because there's no
you really can't on Instagram it's no
ads or anything not really I guess you
can get sponsorships but I you know I
feel that's I don't know you have a
patreon or something like that or people
own yeah I haven't done that and maybe
that's what maybe that's the direction
I'm looking at these options is it
patreon is it finding a backer who will
back something though you really stretch
your wings and try but you know again
the goal is to do this in a way that has
integrity and is about what the things
we've talked about focusing on
understanding in the audience and so you
just want to get in the situation where
you're again just like servicing how
many eyeballs can write you're beholden
to yeah yeah i mean i i've made that
decision so far for the podcast where
i'm I don't have ads I could make more
money if I had ads but it's a little bit
less fun to have the ads and you know
there's some good things out there but I
don't care what mattress you sleep on
all companies love advertising on
podcast so I'm asking people to support
through patreon or through PayPal or
whatever so it's great yeah you know if
they do they show up and they do they do
yeah you know I'm mostly grateful like
people are willing you know if I if
someone gives me a dollar per episode I
think that they if it's an hour and a
half of talking they're getting dollars
worth or out of it and but I still feel
extraordinarily grateful when they do
yeah it's great that's nice yeah but you
know you're doing something a little bit
different like I would I talked on one
podcast episode with Mahon a ruler who
is an expert in cryptocurrency
blockchain and things like that and I
said what we really need is just a
non-optional you can listen to this but
you pay a nickel
right like most people would do that
yeah I so agree but it's the technology
isn't quite there yeah really
not yet I mean how long they it could be
very soon but the whole cryptocurrency
thing is just in so much terms yeah
right I think actually the
technologically it could happen but the
buy-in is not quite very well you know
the numbers show people are more and
more willing to pay for their content
and subscriptions are way up that's
right and so I think there's an
increasing consciousness that you got to
support these sources yeah or they'll go
away or your and you end up with your
Uncle Fred giving you the news on
Facebook well I'm one of those people
who you know subscribes to a couple of
real newspapers and magazines just
because I want to support journalism
when they show up as paper forms in your
house no I don't get paper forms I get
nothing right like it's things I could
get on the internet for free the New
York Times or whatever but I'm willing
to pay for 20 bucks yeah I with you know
cuz it does matter and you know the
world is getting more complicated it's
not gonna get any simpler and getting
reliable news reporting matters right
yes yeah so it's but that's not all
you're doing like not only are you
reporting the news and trying to start a
whole new not only new particular news
operation but a new way of doing the
news but you have a novel coming out
yeah right oh my god made you decide to
do that so much free time you just have
to know buildings of somehow I wanted to
do something that would make me feel
like I was very bad at my task so I I'd
always wanted to read a novel
a write a novel I loved trashy novels
when I was a kid and I wanted to write
them when I grew up and then I ended up
being a journalist instead and so I
thought when I was leaving it was really
important for me so I left before Trump
right but I saw what was happening in
the industry and I thought I really want
people to understand what goes into the
making of the news and what it's like
every day and there's two ways to do
that to write a tell-all where you rip
people and hurt people and you know I
just didn't want to be part of that yeah
but I still wanted the story to be told
so I wrote it as a novel and it's called
savage news and it's about a young
female reporter named Natalie Savage and
she basically is always wanted to be
White House correspondent and gets to a
cable news channel and they put her at
the White House
just as the first lady disappears and
she has to chase the scandal of the
missing first lady but she realizes
along the way something else much more
serious is happening and her network
won't let her report the more serious
story because it won't rate and there
all these other components she's
competing with the man and they're in a
contest to get the White House job yeah
okay so there's lots of drama
was it fun that he had fun writing the
book in the end I had such a blast and
it was really and it's funny so that's
that was a fun part and being able to
tell the stories was so fun but it turns
out there's like a whole craft to
writing a novel you can't just like
write your story I don't think that's
true at all I think it's like thank you
that appears well that's gonna ask like
characterization you know how much you
describe and things like that was there
a lot of given for give-and-take with no
editors and readers and so well the new
way you do a novel is you hire an editor
as you're doing it you send the editor
the pages to give you feedback so you're
in conversation with somebody who knows
this space and so I was constantly in
conversation and one of the one of the
challenges has always been to tell
people they're like well this seems
larger than life and you're like no no
that literally happened every day yeah
like I'd call my reporter friends and
like you're not gonna believe the stuff
they think is crazy and they're like no
no it happened to me a minute ago can
you give us one little example yeah I'll
give you an example she is fighting
fighting fighting to prove herself at
the White House and she finally Annette
nails this one scoop and she runs and
tells her boss the scoop so that she can
get on air and they're like run to the
camera get and by the time she gets on
the camera she goes up live just as she
watches her male competition report that
scoop she got and so the boss gave it to
the guy and my friends were like so
people outside the news business think
that would never happen cartoonishly
evil yeah right happens all day every
day yeah we're gonna learn a lot what
was the novel called again savage SAV a
GE news savage news so something that's
come out all in all these different
aspects that you know CNN Instagram the
novel is that maybe it's worth talking
to women as well as men right I mean
this is it clearly something that we
don't always do in our society you know
how important is that to you that's a
big part of this yeah we haven't gotten
to that I mean part of the book is about
reporting while
female and I don't get gruesome but
there's sexual harassment in the book
there's me too and in the process of
writing the book so many people told me
to take that out nobody wants to read
about that that seems implausible men or
women told you that both and then the
Harvey Weinstein thing happened and
everyone calls me up no like put it back
in back in like so in a way writing the
novel was a parallel of the experience
which is you're not allowed to talk
about this stuff and one of my critiques
is that we do need much more diversity
not just women but diversity in general
at the highest levels of these companies
because who decides what counts as news
is completely limited by your own
experience and so if you're a black
woman who comes from Ohio what you think
counts as news is going to be pretty
different from somebody on the Upper
West Side of New York and and what and
we don't have enough of that and so yeah
I think it's really important that you
have women in decision-making roles and
CBS just named their first female news
president I didn't know that who is it
her name's Susan Zorinsky oh and here's
a little trivia factoid she was the
model for the Holly Hunter character on
broadcast news okay that's a good
starting point right there so and she's
legend in the news business and she's a
badass I do think that you know there's
this feeling among in some quarters that
sure it's good to be fair to men and
women and white people black people
whatever but anyone can do it right and
there's a countervailing opinion like no
as well intentioned as you are there's
something about living the experience
that gives you a perspective that you
don't have other well I'll just tell you
this the research shows that when you
have a woman running a newsroom versus a
man running a newsroom the way the
coverage is done is very different the
way the coverage is done when a woman's
running it is much more about you have
many more humans in the story saying it
impacted me this way and there's a more
I mean it's cliche to say it's more
empathic but there is more of an empathy
in it it's much more connected to the
human level and when the guys are doing
it it's much more theoretical the game
the fight and this is my thesis on why
they say women like
political and foreign coverage less
because we don't take the time to
connect it to the you right and if you
bring it back to the human level the
female audience will engage more the
technical term for this in philosophy
would be standpoint epistemology we're
talking about this on another podcast
but yeah I mean epistemology is the way
that we learn things the way that we
know things the way we justify what we
know and guess what people coming from
different perspectives of the world do
that differently even if it's the same
truth right it's not a matter being
relativistic about what is right and
what is wrong but we pick out certain
things that's important or or roots to
getting there depending on where we come
from and gender would clearly have a be
a factor in filtering that's hugely
important yeah I mean so you mentioned
the fact that one of your draws toward
Instagram was the fact that there's lot
of women on Instagram and you know I'd
never thought about it that way I'm on
Twitter more than anything else a little
bit of blogging and you know the podcast
and everything and being a scientist
coming from where I come from a large
majority of my audience is men not women
I would love it if there were a larger
fraction to look at maybe I feel bring
Instagram yeah maybe I should be on
Instagram more I use Instagram just for
the silliest most trivial reasons
pictures of my cats and yeah I'm allowed
to but maybe there's you know in many
many ways certainly in science we could
do a better job of reaching audiences
that we don't you know I was a science
consultant on the original four movie oh
not a lot of science in that movie but
part of the motivation was that Natalie
Portman played a role the physicist and
you almost didn't notice while watching
the movie but at least we had hopes that
you know there's gonna be some young
girl who would see that and sort of
identify like that and that that movie
will reach a lot more people than I ever
will with all the books I ever do or all
the podcasts they ever record well
representation makes a huge difference
just having it in a different form
matters and I certainly think you know
what I've been talking about this
business I'm doing and when I pitch it
and say that you know the first audience
is female I get a lot of pushback from
men who are like I hate the news too why
are you trying to reach me no no I am
you it's for you too
so do they realize the irony and that
you know the last 500 years or whatever
other side they weren't
but the stories I mean this out because
maybe people listening don't know you
would never know from seeing your
Instagram feed that there was anything
especially female about it you're doing
the same topics that everyone else cut
right and that is a challenge is that
people think oh you're doing girls news
or women's news and no no I'm doing the
news baking tips or you know style of
fashion at home no no I you know I have
you know syria's they're you know what's
the latest in Yemen you know kind of you
know this is hard stuff I'm just trying
to the better way to say it is I try to
think of the stories and bring feminine
values into the way I make sense of it I
am so hardwired to be the other way
right like I know how to cover news as
sports I'm an I'm like a color
commentator or whatever you call this
point so how do you bring another point
of view into it and so that's what I'm
trying to do but this gives you
credibility right only Nixon can go to
China like you that you've done the work
in playing that game yeah way yeah right
so let's just to close up what is tell
the future a little bit like are you
more or less optimistic about the future
of news and how we get it do you see
people debate about the effects of the
internet and social media and
fragmentation there's clearly both good
aspects and bad aspects how should we
bet well I have to say my experience has
been so rewarding that I'm optimistic
because I get so much feedback from the
audience that says I stopped watching
the news thank you for giving me news
without a panic attack and or you've
taken the toxicity out of the news I can
what I can watch you before bed and feel
calm and I can sleep and so it's it's
instructive not because they're giving
me compliments but because they want the
information and one of the things I was
constantly told is people aren't they're
checked out they don't care they don't
want to know and as long as you have an
audience that wants to know we will find
ways to tell it and and it turns out
that by telling it with integrity and
discipline and empathy you get an
audience so I think that in in having
success in this space it will encourage
other people to try this as well yeah I
think that I mean for one thing
that's a great accomplishment because
the stories you're bringing them are not
intrinsically calming no that's true I
feel bad because I'm like oh my god but
the point what you're pointing out is it
is traditional ESPN Talking Heads motif
makes it even worse like reveille t'sit
and yes and and there's a piece of this
that I'm still trying to crack which is
people want solutions and it's not how
are we gonna solve the government
shutdown but I'll tell you the story the
government shutdown which doesn't have a
resolution but here's a story about a
company that's rescuing you know garbage
out of the ocean they've had enormous
success as long as you're reminding
people that over the course of history
we've found ways to solve the hard
problems it gives them the optimism to
feel this too can be solved I think so
I'm gonna I'm gonna come down on your
side being a little optimistic here
because I know that whether it's you
know doing this podcast or giving talks
about science or being on TV talking
about the multiverse I've always
positively encouraged when people
stretch out to sort of learn these hard
new things and respond to them I think
that you know we condescend a little bit
to our audiences and when we refuse to
do that we're rewarded absolutely
they're not there they're not they just
don't know explain the basics and
they're with you
yeah and that's what's really exciting
is people respond to that they're like
sponges they want to know good well I
hope we can push a couple more
subscribers you on this podcast then you
know you're helping making me a little
bit more optimistic about the news Shawn
it's such an honor to be on with you
really this is a pleasure thanks Jessica
thanks so much we'll be on the podcast
thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]